hello welcome to this video on leash are
all nine chess what can we do let's do
the Black Knight Stingo probably we
transpose into the names o again they're
almost check looks like some bull go the
type of position yeah this sad in
turning him tournament game once and got
a very very decent position we should
want air force normally not that well
placed as it runs into an kooky five
check I can take with the bishop now for
a decent position no it doesn't okay
that looks pretty okay I mean having a
very good fluent development here you
aphorism so you form e 4 opens up his
bishop that is what i don't like about
it 94 as an interesting choice let's do
that Quincy to Bishop f5 looks very
attractive for black and Queen you three
I go and we're five force my idea and at
square five just trying to to limit
white I mean it's not easily developing
now we should one f1 scale of the
problem okay as possible that i thought
the Queen to have seven here where is he
having some kind of tactic ya know
attacking the corn not sure that I will
really take it but not a bad spot on f7
and still he's not developing easily
it would be nice if I had f4 like f for
Queen takes Bishop f5 trapping the Queen
but yes Queen d5 it's got just one
square but one square is enough so we
should 360 on yeah maybe that looks like
a temp oh yeah again i'm not sure that i
will take the palm but yeah five
something like that i had expected
otherwise he's not really yeah
untangling his pieces i came i can t go
i can let him take I wonder if g6 is a
move to recapture with the pawn this is
that I need to cancel long in that case
and I don't really see how that is going
to happen
huh
can also teach you form just play simple
stuff let's let's take it play Queen
takes Bishop c4 is a porn at least it
takes with the porn our Castle short
have 94 I got back you the player can
play 94 immediately now I'm not sure
canceling is fine I am not quite sure
what this move is now maybe try
something no I'm something completely
unexpected 94 also was interesting with
not sure that there is a huge difference
in quality between the two moose so just
castle yo that is a different song he
threatening now but oops age 26 s what i
wanted to do yeah Bishop Bishop f5 right
yeah let's just go push about 50 I said
to a technical 94 is also strong I think
ok midst 94 threatens on f3 and Bishop
f5
yeah again Bishop f5 looks pretty strong
now you cannot take with the Queen that
just lose this the Queen I came some
yeah I wanted to take with the Queen
that rope g6 this bit annoying I even
though I mean look g6 King a jade
and they're just winning i mean if not
check i'll be angry but I mean I could
have taken actually finish five maybe I
could have taken the rook but that's not
bad c1 is hanging with check i think i
mean i think is wrong i know that it
does hang with check and there are some
other things age floor for example also
hangs so i think i'll take age for now
still checking the group on g6 and nf2
it's like almost made white resigns yeah
it was a bad opening i think here check
here you should take with the bishop
just a a good good way to play that
bishop is better here inside of the pawn
Shane Latakia maybe I'm the id-5 or or
this one and this looks normal I mean
compared to a news online is lost to
move but it's still okay for white now
this is this is already uncomfortable i
think im just far better developed and
yeah okay the engine wants to play
Bishop f5 that's it's also interesting
of course but i was a bit unsure about
this okay night deep voice is winning
already ok now i didn't see that one but
this is not bad pretty sure about it
moves see one yeah here you can argue if
this should be six the Prasad most
precise me or or canceling i went bishop
you six and he played that move you know
i think that's a good choice i mean
otherwise white is not going to get ever
out of this bind so I took it teach
avani foyer that that's the mistake I
was I already
this might be the problem with this and
the engine is is confirming here it only
gives me a slight advantage it's
material equality let's say like here
here but of course why it is completely
fully in the game I mean yes those
bishops I'm play now and I mean it's a
very unconventional position that I
don't mind playing but that certainly is
something entirely different to the game
where he was yeah just lost you lost I
think this is probably just lost yeah
confirmed by the stock fish engine- to
ya 94 is good for sure and five and
eight wins yeah I think I can take the
rook I mean I saw that just after I
played King a trade but key a jade
should win as well right yeah the thing
is he had check and I can go here and
now he's out of checks and I'm still
threatening here here and so on so I
could have just taken the rook but that
also wins is just one two three pieces
hanging and three is a bit much plus
they have to issue so he resigned yeah
he should play the opening differently
what's on the under huge pressures they
are from the get-go okay well thanks for
watching